and please bear with me while I get our
live stream started for a LinkedIn
audience this will take
just about 30 seconds
and all right and
Welcome to our LinkedIn audience our
YouTube audience and everyone who's here
live on WebEx my name is Stuart Creek
I'm a marketing manager here at simply
learn
and today I'm here with Burg vendor who
will be conducting our
learn it live software development
master class
addressing the front end of consumer
e-commerce apps
um
if you were with us for our last session
we talked about the back end design of
an e-commerce app like Amazon
and so we'll be looking at the front end
today uh if you're on the WebEx app
please enter your questions for revendra
in the Q a panel we'll cue those up for
him and get to them at the uh
end of the session in the Q a period
um you can also put things in the chat
um not no guarantee that we'll be able
to take those as they come in but
questions in the Q a we will definitely
take and if you are watching on the live
stream please put your questions in the
comments we have folks who can I'll pass
those on to us
um we also have a couple of questions
we're going to ask
along the way in the first one
is this one
which is uh just to get a feel for who's
in the audience how much work experience
do you have
not necessarily in software but just
in the workplace
after your degree or if you're in still
College let us know
and also we're doing a check in on how
people are doing we've been doing that
throughout the pandemic
doesn't see how people are holding up as
the situation changes constantly around
us
about 10 seconds get your answers in
and we're just about to close the poll
now
and
all right vendor we have an audience
that kind of tilts towards
books were still in school at this point
and uh
otherwise it's a fairly even
distribution
and most everybody is doing
um
well or okay today so we're glad to hear
that
with that I'm going to
um go ahead and let you introduce
yourself and start the session so I'm
going to stop sharing my screen and
allow you to share yours
yeah sure
so uh
let me introduce myself to you before I
share my screen just share my screen as
well
okay
it's best invisible to all of you
yeah it is
okay so myself
currently I'm working as a staff
software engineering one of the top tech
companies I would say fortune and
companies currently I hold nine years of
experience in net industry and I am
conducting various multi like training
sessions across different topics
I keep taking masterclass sessions so I
regularly especially
on full FSA topics where I speak about
designing top designing some of the fsds
things and also designing the
some of the Google Maps or any of such
things and today today's agenda is
continuation of whatever I've discussed
in the last time when we had this
session so last time this is just
introduction about me again this is was
talking about similar concept
okay so I'll just close this
okay so I'll just do a quick intro of
whatever we discussed in the last week
last week in the sense last time
so in the last time what do you
discussed I'll just open that uh
document where we I've downloaded on all
the pointers just a second
and my vendor if you could zoom in on
your screen a bit that would be helpful
any button now
yeah that's getting better
okay
okay this was the back end discussion I
had with all of you I mean people who
already attended last week but still
I'll get I would like to do this
introduction or or I would say five to
five minutes about this before I start
this people who are joined only for
today for them I want to be get up and
running with what's been discussed
so when we discussed last time I just I
created the entire springboot
application
using spring web data jpa MySQL and
lockbox
okay so I have also used
MySQL here
database use this and close this
Master Class com
databases
okay
so these are these are the database I
used
I'll go one by one step by step I'll
explain the briefing in the last last
times one I've created entity called as
product with three information called as
name picture and picture URL
and I've also created the order okay and
the end in the order I've created the
primary key date created status
and the order information with one to
many relationship and I have list of
order product okay why this product
order product is important for us this
is a composite key which will help us in
combine these two and get us the
quantity
okay and this is one to many and I also
discussed about some of the product get
get product and get total price of the
entire order in the order product entity
okay in the repository space I've
created order repository also I have
created the
product repository and order product
repository this repository have created
and I've also shown you guys about a
simple credit operations okay wherein in
fraud service I have to get methods in
the post I have one one method and in
the update I have one under delete I
have one this is just to demonstrate how
can we actually do this
crud operations okay so in the At Last I
spoke about these four in the orders
likewise we did it in the product and
I've exposed some of the methods okay
and I discussed that here in the product
controller I used all these four using
get post uh put and delete in the post
mapping I have had the create product
method which will uh in over I would say
create product as the end point that
this is the end point
which will take the input from the
Postman with the request body and it
creates the product for us in the
backend okay and in the list of all
products it will give me all products
okay so whatever we created last time I
would like to show it to you guys
true
all right
let's select star from
okay it's just some of the things I have
actually I've just put in just before
the session
I got vanished whatever I created last
time so I also have the I can show the
same thing in the year as well so
thank you
localhost
uh
in e84 I guess is the port
8084
products is the response would give me
for the products okay and also we have
individually we can get the information
about the products
if I say one enter
it gives me the
a single product
okay that's about the post mapping get
mapping get mapping for a specific
product and also I've made this
modification
which will take the ID
along with the path variable and also
the request body which is modified once
okay
and finally we have delete mapping these
are some of the things I discussed last
week
or whenever we discussed
Okay so in these things if you guys have
any questions or such things you can let
me know before I start the next one
today topic is all about talking about
the front end okay where I'll discuss
about angular okay
let's discuss about the front end year
so
I want to break it into two pieces
first of all I'll build very
basic products page
class after that I will show you already
built project because I don't have
enough time to show everything
the back end is made of spring boot the
backend is spring boot which is what I
discussed
in the last time
okay
so this is the agenda
let us
get started
so I have created NG new
I say
become
angular I'll create everything from
scratch so that if you also get a chance
to create something like this you will
be able to get this same experience the
way I'm getting I can select any of the
things I'll set up CSS for now it will
create the public for me and I'll leave
it the same way okay
it will just take a minute or so to get
itself up and running let's give it a
minute
this wait let me complete this so that
I'll be related completed then I'll be
able to show you guys
only one
last master class I was talking about
backend today I'm talking about front
end that's it
I hope my screen is visible to all of
you right
yes it should be
okay thank you thank you for the
confirmations to what
because someone told like they can't see
my skin that's why I'm already sharing
my screen
okay now I got the application running
just to show you whether it is working
or not I can say npm start now that will
start the application
okay sorry I have to change directory
npm start
okay it seems to have compiled and if I
go here under say localhost 4200
will give me these things for me
and I don't want any of these things let
us expand this
Source app
component HTML
I would say
H1 this is
Master Class
now you see you get this let me actually
install the angular here
and BMI reboot strap
and read the latest
okay and then I have to
Point Style
and create
fourth
I hope this is the right path
to get it
so once you do this you'll have this
bootstrap installed in your system how
can you confirm that I'll just show you
so you can say div dot container because
I'll be using a bootstrap extensively
now
MP3
and then uh BG primary
and then text White
foreign
so I will now make it as
container
fluid
Okay so
[Music]
let us leave the CSS aside for now our
first attempt would be
get this
products into the content that is the
first attempt for that I will build a
very basic table for now of course we
are building the entire UI of e-commerce
but my initial build up is I want to get
this
data from the back end to the front end
for that what and all we need let's
focus on that first
okay so for that what I need is you want
to make sure that I will be writing a
service first so for that Ng
yes
ND generate service
[Music]
product
services
like flash
now if you see you will have a folder
called as Services inside the lava
service.ts if you ask me what is this
this is the injectable which is used to
connect to the back end and get the data
for us
okay the next thing what I'm going to
write is
I need first of all
communicate to the back end right I have
to have the right URL with me okay so I
have to import the HTTP client for us
import
http
client because sometimes it will not
actually import as it is
angular
slash common
slash
client
oh sorry http
okay now that I have this with me
actually I can
inject this in my Constructor so how do
I do this I say private http
and I can say HTTP client that's it if
you do this
you will be able to get the contents now
the first picture I'm good on it is get
all products
I would say return
start
HTTP dot get off
this Dot
products URL which I'm going to Define
now
uh otherwise
let's say products is equals to
console.log
products
this would be I'll create the constraint
over here for this
answer is equal store
I'll get this guy over here
so this is done
now let us
choose this inject the service in some
other case and test whether it is
working fine or not
for that reason I will create a product
component in GG
t t means components ND green is
generate
component slash
correct
I'm going to create the products for me
in the components here if you see
okay
so here
what I'm going to say I'm going to
inject this
product service for now
you can actually name it as e-commerce
service or anything is fine
so I will say here
private
product services
all right now next after this
I will create a
local variable here
saying that
product
s
this is of type
product okay
you might be wondering what is this
product where do I product
actually speaking I'll be creating one
model for this guy
so I will create a folder over here
because it is like a video for me now
which is coming from the front end
so I say model
or I will rename as models
product
dot model dot yes
here I would say export
class
product
ID
number let us see what null information
I have with me
these are the four instrumental right
so
name
is a string
price is a number
three wirelessly
let us create the Constructor for the
same
this guy
and this
I have to initialize one of them then I
will go automatically it's like a
creating your class
okay
dot ID
is equals to ID
this dot name is equals to name
so our price is equals to price
equals to
URL
foreign
the next thing is
I have to create similar models which
are there here I have Protestant
now what is the next
product we have done understood now we
have
orders also we have product orders
okay let us create this
order product as the single thing okay
this particular guy
okay okay
so let us create the model also but we
can pause it for a while because we are
focusing on getting this product in
first place here
so let us do this
let us finish this exercise of getting
this data in the first place okay
so now
have injected here
on NG on any type can say load products
can create a method over here
I mean this is the me of method I'm
putting it here
I can say this Dot productservice dot
get all products
they created I'm going to subscribe
so I have to return here something
subscribe for the product
okay and in the subscription whatever
products I'm gonna get
it will be of any
with this
I will set the
start products
it equals to products
also why it is having error
this is the reason
so combine takes two parameters
that's why the data was coming and uh
now the shares should go away.log
yes
anyway you can see this
this Dot
products dot for each
whatever product I'm getting here
I'll go through them
let us come to this in a while but let's
stop it here and we'll see whether we
are getting data or not
but why it is a problem
let us leave all these things let us get
product and see what what it is
happening or not I wanted to show
something else honest
of X is equals to products I got here
so let us try to control log and check
whether this is working or not
yes and then start totally I meant
I will say console.log
products
so I will just go to the UI
and I will
go to the inspect
and I need to invoke this refresh
okay why did I start getting involved is
because this component is not all
invoked in any manner
uh let me do this I'll go to this guy
and I will take the product
and I will insert it in the yes
okay I'll say this
now those things I mean I get some
response that's okay
this is what I actually wanted these
three first of all I wanted to show this
error to you the main reason why you're
getting this error because I have I
haven't inserted HTTP client module in
the app dot model.ts I if you are
angular developer
I'm 10 sure you guys might have
encountered this error
okay now that data is gone you got the
observable
okay so we were able to successfully get
this
data for us
so now with that
I'll subscribe
data goes to
console.log
data is
data
okay let us verify this again
okay again the skills I wanted to show
you guys because whenever this goes to
the back end it will actually block us
from performing right for this there is
one straightforward solution this this
is called as cross origin request
service okay generally this gets blocked
we need to resolve this
we have to go to the back end and we
need to allow from the spring
I'll
there are other for all good ways but
foreign
okay so I will let my uh product
controller only allow
or this guy
someone okay observe this if this error
is coming means I'll just paste here
also here so that you guys face seller
means I mean this is not a permanent
solution I am telling you again this
solution just for the sake of continuing
our application okay now if I stop
he or restart my application
see it's it's starting
I'm always doing showing step by step
okay so now if I refresh
instead of earlier whatever problem I
got now I got the data itself
so observe the pattern first I what I
what issue I faced the issue I what I
faced is
I was not able to get any product at all
in first place
so
HTTP didn't work for me the problem I
got is no provider something was there I
fixed it I moved on further then it was
not able to connect to the back end
and the problem was
this and now that I am able to
successfully come to the back end
I have the red eye with me and that is
what is data is here
I'll show this data in a simple tabular
format for you just to complete the flow
after that I will show you already built
application
so here
what I can say
table dot table dot table
stripe inside that let me have a table
header table row
table uh data or table header into
four
Plus
table body inside that let me have a
table row
4.
sorry enter the TD into four I want to
have okay so inside this cable I want to
have table header and this got a summit
abbreviation
if you are wondering what is that I'm
getting here
this is the shortcut
let me comment this
I would say
product ID
material number for trading
name
price
products
[Music]
we have to get the actual uh
index for us so you put semicolon
say let a is equals to index
okay
why you can't hear anything when other
people can hear everything clearly
so I plus 1 I'll put here because index
are from 0
and here I put each product dot ID
and same thing I'll be putting each
product dot name
each product dot price
URL
Okay so
I come back here
okay I will actually remove the
is from the outside
products
HTML file
so I'll keep a button over here because
the problem happening I got it the
problem Happening Here is observe
observe this code okay first table loads
then this is coming up right that is the
problem
so whenever if you want to avoid the
problems what you can do is you can
actually
invoke this with the help of a button or
something else okay so I'll add this
particular button over here
I'll move this inside a div Dot
container Dot
mt3 T3 Dot
okay that's enough
button dot vtn dot vtn
primary
load
products
okay
and I want
Ng
div
and G if
products dot length is greater than zero
only then for this data otherwise don't
show this data
so here
on click
get products
hi learner are you looking to get ahead
in the growing field of business
analytics here's your chance get a
world-class University education and
develop job-ready scores from the
Comforts of home
it is defined
TS
oh I'm really sorry it is supposed to
bind not this kind of an element it is
Handler you have to bind here okay it is
not the on click and everything what we
did use in angle sorry other things also
having problems
partner is not terminated
anyway
not products
please including there is something
wrong
no no no no
get all products
this is there and in this guy
ng4 of products but let me remove this
for a while a little bit causing problem
greeting cards
oh
my bad
this is empty because
this dot product in this case
my bad
so I I was always wondered that I
already said I already said products in
component I will
uh
it would be
this dot point is equal to
data
data I'll check here
okay now this is of
I can't directly assign this as it is
because this is of expecting it to be in
a product
so I will just modify this to be
given as
product all right
if you come back
to this guy where is that yes now that
problem is gone
this is wrong
so one error is gone and now we'll come
back to this guy each product of
products keeps having the product
let me put this over here
that is having the right information
then what is wrong with this
ID
yeah it does verify whether it is coming
or not
yes I am getting it
I am getting everything in the one
product only
okay there is some formatting problem
here so for now I will change all these
things into any so that I will not get
this problem
uh
okay so we got the products right so
it's coming as an array only for me one
though I did this conversion
product of zero let me see
I got it
why it is not getting information in the
G
or
let
product of
products
PD
or deck
dot ID
uh
sometimes I forget very badly this
basics
went like this
sorry guys
anyway
sorry for that hassle so if you click
even though this load product is not
there also it will actually work
because this is always having that clear
bending in place the moment the data is
filled it locked automatically get that
so
this is how you actually get the
end-to-end communication I'll repeat
I'll explain everything once
sorry for my syntactical mistakes most
of them were right the problem happened
is in the fetch part here okay so first
thing I did is I get all the products
here
once I got the products then what I did
is I loaded the products here
once I loaded the products I subscribed
to them and got these products and I
said it to the products variable in the
local
TS file right once that is done what
next I done is I have loaded that
content in the HTML so for this I took
help off okay I can actually add this
index also let I is equals to index
index is a built-in variable for us
so IE Plus
one
yeah
both looks the same
how can that happen yes now
one two three four five name it should
be name
ID is okay and here I should have the
name
product ID is also look the same because
in the back end if you see HC one and
one two three four five that's why these
numbers are same don't get confused it
is different is different
I don't want them both of them to be
next to each other because if I do that
that causes a problem for me it will
confuse you and that's why I kept the
name in one place ID in one place okay
this is how one entire end-to-end
application how this works now it is not
an incomes application right
how can I do this I will show you that
build code because if I keep writing the
code I will not be able to finish in the
entire class
for the same reason I've already written
the entire code end to end before the
class and kept it ready
so that I can explain that code to you
and I'll show you the role that works
okay
so npm I'll stop this application
whatever I'm just doing here
okay I'll just
stop this
uh end
top
yes
now I'll start this application
npm start before I start I'll go to the
e-commerce service dot this one 84 and
84.
let us see the actual output first then
we'll I'll show you the actual code and
explain the code to you
I will share the code for the whatever I
built in the class so that you can use
it for your references
let me get this application up and
running
okay it seems to the application is come
up now I'll refresh
it pinched of course this I've returned
before the class okay I'll just explain
the code to you what happened okay and
also the back end is still the same but
the front end is completely written in a
different format okay the code is like
this
so I'll let me start from the uh app
component.js in this I have the app
computer HTML here I have app e-commerce
as the first component in place okay
in this if I go here and if I
for this wherever I have this matching
it is present in the Commerce component
dot PS okay this is the basic page okay
so I have in place here I have used all
neutral components that means I'm all
almost using all the components in one
place okay and this is the place where I
have all the important information okay
and if you see I have already loaded the
products
I've also have this
entire HTML in place here the HTML shows
view child is a way to bind multiple
components okay
let's say you have
component a you have component B we have
worked with held like parental
combination or parent
child child comp parents communication
there is one way you can do it with the
help of add direct input at that output
right the same way we can do V chain
also here okay feature also provides
same feature for us where it helps us to
communicate between these two
and it's a decorator in this case
okay so here what I've done is I have
built the entire using all bootstrap
things
and I have the NJ class so this concept
is little big okay I'll brief you guys
once the concepts whatever I used here
I've used the all property bindings this
is property binding written this is NG
class this is also one of the property
binding
and I have actually implemented this if
you see this response this is the entire
nav click bar I have and this is UL okay
this is the reason we have all this one
two three four five six
that is the help of this guy and finally
the app on the other side shopping cart
this one it's right there whatever we
have right that is with the help of
I'll take this to the right
that is with the help of this
information okay here
you have this
shopping cart now let's say add to cart
I increase this quantity to one and I
say add to cart increase quantity one
reset so
add to cart now if you see you have
these three information I bought account
this is the order page I pay
successfully
this is this is the simple application
I've developed
I come back to this
I've explained this route to you and
this is the page where I have loaded
this yeah all
ul's UL is the one which contains the
current information for each and every
small element if I come to TS file here
I have
sorry here I have actually loaded all
the information this
products component I've loaded shopping
cart component I've loaded order
component I've loaded product C is a
product component inside this if you
notice I have loaded the products again
this also with a similar concept get out
products if you notice here it will get
us the product that's it
nothing much and it inside that I am
loading all the products and I'm also
creating the product order object every
single time to load the product so that
I can use it in the application okay so
that is the help of this block
and in a similar fashion I have loaded
the orders also and of course I have
written some utility function which will
get us the
product index present or not I can
remove element from card how can I
remove element from Curtis I'll go to
home I refresh
add to cart now if you click on removed
element from card it should go away from
here also and this should get reseted
also now whatever was there earlier I
need to show me back the same thing
so that is the help of remove remove
element from the card operation will
will help us from that is why I've
written this index now if I read all
this code to the class I need at least
two hours maybe more that is the reason
I haven't written all of these things in
the class in the class whatever I can
write is one end-to-end communication
that is what I've shown you in first
place now I am able to explain you all
those things in one go
component contain all information about
products and orders okay and this is the
one information which is communicating
with us for order product information
okay
so I have add to cart I have removed
from cart I have also get product next I
have also esport selected because I
should get to know right the moment I
click on this
which is the one currently I'm selecting
that is the reason I have that
particular place idea in place under
load orders reset is the one the moment
technical account reset everything will
set to their original one okay so that's
about products if you see about the
orders similar way we have orders also
here here we loaded the all the orders
I have to load the total over here why
this is
I need to calculate whatever has been
modified in the UI okay and also finally
the moment I click on pay I don't do
anything there is just it will add those
combination in the back end now if you
see select star from
orders
is nothing
okay because
I have to cart
add to cart
check out the
system communication gap might have
happened here
uh
the problem is cars problem here also
that is haunting us where is this
okay I haven't done the order controller
again here okay so that is the reason so
if if I have to write that again that's
if you if you have written that this
problem you won't face there okay
so uh with that I have came to end of
today's session
so I hope it it was enough to understand
one end to the other end
yeah I think I'm done from my side
Stuart
and ticket all right thank you so much
um
so let's ask a few of the questions that
came in from the audience
and you can see his Rook vendricks
explained we wanted to show you the uh
the basics that he could cover in an
hour
um in our actual courses
we go much deeper and
one of our multi-course programs you
would end up in a Capstone project
where you would take on something of
this nature but you would do it all the
way from front end to back end to
merchandising and displaying product
images
and really creating the the full
um experience so this is just uh this
has been a example of the process that's
going to take you step by step being
able to do that type of thing
um
we had a question from garden chart uh
I'm sorry for mangling your name
um
do we need to install anything for
shortcuts or is it
in Visual Studio
he was looking at that part while you
were doing
the question actually uh where is the
question is what it's in the chat uh do
you need to install anything for the
shortcut that you're implementing or no
no I told that answer in the class
itself the answer is no
okay
UBS code a feature itself and he was
also asking about a view child at that
function I explained that also it's it's
just like your communication between
components I have a component a
component B just like you use input
output in the different components right
same way virtual also provides such
features you can inject that particular
component in the current component
that's the common combination
[Music]
it's not that simple
we have a question about we got a couple
questions about placements and
um enrolling in the Capstone project I
think I'm going to go ahead and go on to
that because I don't see uh many other
questions about the uh
subject matter but I do want to go ahead
and
um
talk about
just done that
um
if he
want to learn how to become a full stack
Java developer
especially for people this is a program
designed for people
with less than three years of experience
and this is a program that offers a 100
job guarantee I'll explain what that
means in just a moment but the full
stack Java developer program includes
um
courses of the type that render just
showed you but and I'll go into that in
a minute as well the comprehensive full
curriculum that takes you from
uh beginner status all the way to full
stack Java developer it includes
integrated case studies and projects so
you get to do the type of thing that rug
vendors showed you under the direction
of instructors like him where you do
this on your
um
online project system it's part of the
integrated learning platform
you have weekly classes that with live
instructors so that you can go through
step by step and
ask the instructor and get feedback from
your peers and the work between the
weekly classes is all on your own
schedule because the platform's
available 24 7. and the guaranteed job
offer
um
I'll hit in a moment here's the
curriculum this program starts with a
full stack Java developer welcome class
orientation but you start with uh
object-oriented programming for with
Java
you move on to the back end
then you learn how to use Frameworks uh
in a way that's compatible with devops
which is the
modern tool for
software deployment and continuous
integration and
continuous deployment and then
um
you learn how to create
the front end and much more depth
as you saw today
um
and then finally the Capstone project
which takes everything you've learned in
this set of courses and integrates it
into a final full stack development
project that's based on an industry
class problem you also have the ability
you know the option of taking the
elective depending on your interest and
your time schedule the elective is
included for free
testing you know devops lifecycle which
is an important aspect modern software
development and you end up with the
certificate that shows that you have
completed the course along with all the
projects including the pre-apportone
projects that are in your portfolio
to demonstrate to your future employers
but when we talk about future employers
and this program job guarantee aspect of
this program is available only in India
as we partnered with a number of
employers in India who have
told us that they can basically take on
as many full stack Program full SEC
developer graduates as we can produce
they know our reputation for helping
people become extremely proficient so uh
they have said that within six months of
completing the program and getting your
certificate
provided you follow the
job search instructions that we give you
they one of them will offer you a
written job guarantee within that
six-month period or you'll receive your
program fees refunded in full again this
is only offered to Learners in India
because you do have to be able to take a
job with an Indian employer for a job
guarantee to work so unfortunately we
can't offer it other countries around
the world
but um we are working on that but I just
wanted to let folks in India know that
this program is available for people
elsewhere we do have other full stack
Java developer boot camps that are
available that don't include job
guarantee but do include some job
assistance
so just a quick question based on this
thumbnail sketch of what I've told you
is this something that you might be
interested in and would you like to find
out more so
real simple question are you interested
uh
this type of program and
if you are when would you want to start
and I'll give you just another 20
seconds or so to answer that
yeah
another 10 seconds get your answers in
we'll close the poll in three two one
now
all right
about two-thirds of our audience today
said they're interested in this program
which is great um and I'll share with
you how to get in touch with us and
um some folks are looking at doing it
right away some folks are looking at
doing it farther off in the future what
I'm going to do is put into the chat
the
um
link to the program page which was also
in that QR code
I'll go back to the QR code so that you
can have a moment to ski on it I'm going
to put into the chat
both this link to the program page and
the
email address ask us at simplylearn.net
ask us at simplylearn.net we'll let you
contact the learning consultant and ask
questions about the program
find out more about it and see if it's
something that's right for you
and with that
I want to thank
Greg vendre very much for being
here today and sharing with us his
knowledge and expertise
really appreciated her winter
yeah thank you so much thank you so much
guys I hope you don't waste any more
time right every day on the session and
get maximum use of it okay and I believe
we should see you on the other side of
the screen thank you so much guys bye
and um
just to let you know we have an upcoming
webinar uh next Wednesday
uh for anyone who might be interested in
data science if that's you that's great
if it's if you know of somebody who's
interested in data science and
especially data engineering big data we
have a session with a expert who's got
about 30 years of experience in the
field and heel shares experiences and
advice
and I've just put that also into
the chat window but you can also scan
that QR code
and
with that
I want to thank everyone for being here
today I really appreciate it uh Rick
render appreciates it and
you can keep in touch with us at
simplylearn on Facebook and Twitter or
simply learn on LinkedIn
contact us at ask us at simplylearn.net
for more information on the programs and
we look forward to seeing you at Future
webinars and hopefully welcoming you
into the simply learned learning
community so with that let's conclude
our webinar and again thank you for
being here